[Music]
it's a new season and everyone's got to
watch out because now I'm on my a game
I'm looking for the person that can win
the voice that's my job that's what they
hired me to do
I am definitely here to win if I'm not
gonna win they're not going to be here
at all
I think that every season I'm a threat
to every coach I always want to win it's
fun I feel like there's like an atom and
my lead bromance I don't want to fight
her right now we're getting we're doing
really good today Miley and I are
playing nice today it's been very sweet
she's the best I love her come here
no no no oh whoa you got a focus on it
we're seeing a really amazing version of
Miley right now you're beautiful I love
you I love it I really do love you and
you know why Billie my girl right here
hate to say it but she's growing up a
little bit can you not do your standing
up thing where you stand well you're
standing up I know I'm gonna sit if you
said all so let's do it one two three
love you how different things are this
season when she saw Molly she was like
oh yes donk meet over here people pull
for you when you're behind them but when
you're ahead of them they throw rocks
and things at you hey man look I think
it's time to not talk anymore
because I talk a lot what I'm filing all
these things in the back of my mind why
do you keep trying to help other people
how do gets me Molly at some point it's
all gonna come out Molly I ain't afraid
of life don't come for me not this early
in the day
come on yeah Mike you look so cute Adam
I love my outfit I knew he was because
Adams dream is for me to make a true
country record and when I got on the
light pull on hillbilly I knew who's
gonna love that
I'm taking country real serious Wow
Adams been extra nice to me she's so fun
there's no doubt that you will have fun
hanging out with Miley Cyrus and then he
was like the claws are gonna come out
honey he like said something crazy like
that to me I love this girl right here
but I cannot let her have you I talk a
lot and hopefully you'll learn that
about me because if you will he's trying
to build this like friendship so you
don't see him coming home one thing you
just talk for a long time let me have my
things
no anything making like short breaths I
hear you feel like you're invited I'm
sorry you're feeling my charisma
radiating onto your side you know he's
trying to like deceive us to think that
he's gonna be nice to us so you can
really be like just
three I'm looking forward to winning
this show this year's show it's always
fun to see like what tricks each coach
she's gonna pull out of there I have the
best team ever and I'm gonna win the
whole thing
no Wiley I have the best team ever no I
kind of don't know what wake up to what
Adam up to what my gun do you guys don't
have any steals what a bunch of losers
now look at the other three coaches and
I see disaster you know what mama says
keep your friends close keep your
enemies closer
[Music]